Welcome to the show.
I have some interesting clips to play for
you, some very important stories to discuss,
and one of the biggest areas of concern that's
really it's really turned into kind of a mask
off moment for much of the American right
in the Trumpy and right.
Is the degree to which all sorts of people
have been just falling all over themselves
to defend Kyle Rittenhouse, the shooter in
Kenosha, Wisconsin.
And you might remember that last week, Tucker
Carlson sort of defended the vigilantism of
Kyle Rittenhouse.
And more recently, Tucker Carlson interviewed
one of the attorneys for Kyle Rittenhouse.
I'm going to tell you about some of the other
attorneys momentarily.
It's quite a cast of characters.
But when interviewed, this attorney essentially
turned this into praise for what an accurate
marksman and how controlled the behavior of
Kyle Rittenhouse was that he didn't shoot
more people given the situation.
If you follow what his attorney says here,
given the situation a lesser.
I was going to say a lesser man, a lesser
kid would have maybe shot even more people
than Kyle Rittenhouse did.
So check this out.
And by the way, we're going to get to this.
But it turns out that written houses other
lawyer.
So I mean, to play video of John Pierce.
Kyle Rittenhouse, his other lawyer, appears
to be a Q and on conspiracy theorist, like
every detail is insane.
But let's start with attorney John Pierce
talking about what Kyle Rittenhouse did is
just amazing.
You know, Kyle, the only individuals that
Kyle shot were the three individuals that
were attacking him and putting him at risk
of serious bodily harm or death.
This is a 17 year old kid.
This is this is amazing.
So let me ask you this.
And I think that's a that's a fair point.
He didn't shoot indiscriminately.
And I'm taking your word for it in the first
one because I haven't seen the video.
But in the second two, I have seen the video.
One guy attacked the other guy.
It's, um, it's it's amazing what he did.
What does that even mean?
Amazing is not the word that I think of, like.
It's amazing he didn't shoot more people.
Is that the argument?
Is that an argument that you could make with
a straight face in a court of law?
And I want to reverse reverse the framing.
Just just for a second here, you are going
to see them actually portray part of.
They've shown some of their cards.
They are going to try to portray Kyle Rittenhouse
as a law abiding militia dude who is merely
keeping the peace.
They're going to try to make this 17 year
old who is too young to even be carrying a
gun in this way in Wisconsin legally.
They're going to try to make him into the
Good Samaritan because he was out there helping.
He was helping out there.
And of course, this actually, to some degree
reminds me of the George Zimmerman scenario
with Trayvon Martin, where when a vigilante
claims self-defense, it's like a bank robber
robber saying the teller got aggressive during
the bank robbery or like George Zimmerman
saying I had to defend myself in a confrontation
with Trayvon Martin, which I created by being
a cop wannabe in my neighborhood watch group
or whatever it was it was that he was doing
years ago.
So that's attorney John Pierce saying it's
amazing.
This guy's a hero rather than a criminal.
Then we have the other lawyer, one of the
other lawyers for Kyle Rittenhouse, who's
completely out of his mind.
I'm talking about Lin Wood.
Lin Wood is part of a an organization called
the Fight Back Foundation, which is about
using lawsuits to stop the lies and smears
of the radical left.
And Lin Wood said on Twitter that the Fightback
Foundation is going to be funding Kyle Rittenhouse,
his defense team.
They've got donors holding this kid up as
a hero and funding his defense team.
And Lin Wood's Twitter profile has the hashtag
double you double Yujie one W.J. You might
be wondering, what the hell is that?
It's a Q and on thing and it stands for where
we go one we go all.
It's a line from the 1996 Jeff Bridges Sailing
Adventure White Squall, which they miss a
tribute to President Kennedy.
It's crazy, but it's a Q and on hashtag.
And I mean, you know, step back for a moment.
What better way to make these killings into
political events?
And then to have a political organization
represent the killer.
That's effectively what these lawyers are.
Pierce, the attorney I played a clip of earlier,
was put on leave from his law firm, then called
Pierce Bainbridge Back Price and hacked after
a report found that he was accepting money
from a lender for personal use.
And supposedly it was four million dollars
a month before he was put on leave.
There was a lawsuit from a former partner
accusing employees at the company of financial
and sexual misconduct as well as sexual assault.
I mean, it's like there's just no depths to
the depravity of everybody involved in this
situation.
And he's being represented.
Kyle Rittenhouse is by a group who are as
shady as you would expect in a situation like
this, where they seem to be seeing this more
as an opportunity for self promotion than
to good than an opportunity to do good legal
work.
I now I guess I should mention there's a good
chance they're going to be able to muddy this
up in the process of defending Kyle Rittenhouse.
His lawyer, Lin Wood, is saying, you know,
he didn't actually transport the gun across
state lines.
He got it from a friend, as if that's a defense,
of course.
That means the friend committed a felony by
giving a gun to someone under 18.
He then aided and abetted by by loading that
gun.
Kyle Rittenhouse, of course, was illegally
in possession of that firearm in the state
of Wisconsin.
It's illegal for anyone under 18 to have a
weapon in Wisconsin, even though it's an open
carry state.
Kid should have known that.
But he didn't and pay attention to that and
killed two people.
So there is a lot of really ugly stuff here
that's not even being mentioned.
But they are trying to and partially succeeding
at turning this kid into a hero.
And people are donating to his legal defense
fund.
The lawyers are out of their minds.
And this could be.
I mean, listen, the justice system needs to
work its way, work its process.
But there's already some really ugly red flags
going
on here.